think we started filming in
maybe march of 2009
and where did you film the rum diary
we shot it in puerto rico
and describe if you can
the events of the filming and your
interactions with mr depther in that
time
it was a bit surreal you know filming
in a place like puerto rico it was
beautiful
it takes place in the 50s so
everything
really looked beautiful and you know
cars and clothing
the music it was just it was a very
colorful
um shoot
in general i
i i couldn't have asked for you know
a a better scenario i i was on on film i
mean i was on set
um reading
my books and occasionally johnny would
talk to me and then he started to be
really kind to me
like more open with me
when we'd have hot days filming
you know there'd be this big suv pull up
and
a security guard would kind of
usher me into this car
and it would have the ac blasting
and then be sitting in the back of the
suv
just thinking what a strange experience
the whole thing was and you know
we didn't really have a whole lot of
interaction
on set
until
until we
did a scene that involved
kissing we had a kissing scene and
it didn't feel like a normal
it didn't feel like a normal scene
anymore it felt uh it felt more real
there are certain things that you do in
the job
to
um be professional like when you have to
do that sort of
scene
and you don't like
you
you don't use your tongue if you can't
if you can avoid it there's certain
things that you do to just
maintain a certain line and it just felt
like those lines were blurred i mean he
grabbed my face and pulled me into him
and really kissed me
but we were filming a scene
did he use his tongue
yes okay
did your birthday did you celebrate your
birthday while you were in puerto rico
i did i celebrated
i think
maybe my 23rd birthday there
and what if anything did mr depp do for
your birthday
well we were already kind of
talking about books and poetry and
things like that he gave me a few really
beautiful poetry books
and uh he gave me a bicycle uh like a
vintage bicycle because at the time i
was riding around on a bike and i had a
lot of time off since i was a smaller
role in the movie
and um
yeah i think that was it okay
now did there come a time that um you
ended up
visiting him in his trailer
yes um
i think there was a we would hang out if
you know after
or in between scenes or in between
setups we often were
you know talking about things and would
continue the conversation into the
trailer often with the director bruce
robinson was his name
and then at one point we talk about wine
it's another thing that johnny and i
shared in common i love for
wine red wine
and we were talking about
a kind of wine that i enjoyed and i was
you know going on about how great this
bargain wine was and
i didn't understand you know how much
more sophisticated johnny's taste and
wine was um so i was going on about the
virtues of malbec or something and i
brought him a bottle
of this wine
and i
set it down and at some point i'm i'm
going back to get back to set and he
kind of
kicked his like you know foot up in the
air and
basically kind of lifted the back of my
bathrobe up and
can i just not be there why were you
wearing a bathrobe because i was doing a
scene um it was a period film so it took
place in the 50s and so i had all of
this um
old undergarments that are for that time
era um on
and the scene involved me changing um
so i had all the costume on
and he kind of
picked up the back of my robe with his
boot
and i kind of turned around and
like laughed like giggled you know
um it i wasn't i didn't feel
i just didn't like i didn't know what to
make of it at the time and it just kind
of i just kind of giggled and
batted it away playfully and uh
he he
kind of playfully kind of pushed me down
on this like bed sofa
uh that was in his trailer just playful
um and flirtatious and he said uh yum
and he kind of like lifted up his
eyebrows like that
and i
just giggled
laughed it off kind of batted him away
and you know
moved on went back to set
and were you in a relationship at that
time i was okay and was mr depp in a
relationship at that time that was my
understanding yeah okay
and did anything else of significant
happen during that that time period
while you were filming with mr depp
other than what you've told us
we just had this
you know it was a friendship flirtatious
thing we i
felt chemistry i felt this
other thing that was that went beyond
the pale of my job
for sure
johnny
clearly felt that way about me had
indicated to me that that's how he felt
you